I'm ranking every sword user in anime
from sword fighters who get heart
carried by their own magic to some of
the most skillful Samurai that we have
ever seen all the way to the absolute
peak of Sword Masters who are so
powerful that they might as well be gods
and to really kick this list off let's
reveal our first goder swordsman who is
saber here from the Fate series and W
let me tell you saber is the literal
definition of God's tier because her
unmatched sword skills allow her to
defeat even the strongest sword fighters
with ease but if we're being truly
honest here her true Powers come also
from combining her terrifying swords
play and her legendary magic to wipe out
opponents with truly nuclear scale
attacks so yeah what I wait to start the
ranking but saber is far from the only
god tier sword user because there are a
total of 10 of these monstrous
powerhouses who could wipe out basically
every other sword user on this list but
that's not to say though that this next
group of characters wouldn't put up a
fight though because our next tier is
the Superhuman sword user tier who you
might argue could even hold their own in
a fight against some of the goder
characters and maybe the perfect example
of this tier is Claire from Claymore who
combines her insanely Fast Wind cutter
sword technique with her also
astonishingly powerful yoky
transformations to slice even the
strongest enemies to Pieces however
while these two tiers are just stupidly
overpowered this next tier is my
personal favorite and that's because the
so-called pure samai here is full of the
most incredible natural sword users in
all of anime no magic no superhuman
power just raw beautiful swordsmanship
and of course there might be no better
example of this than afro from Afro
Samurai who uses his lethal techniques
to cut down his enemies while he hunts
down his father's killer now this next
tier however is going to be the most
controversial I think because now we
have the I'm only a strong swordsman
because I'm technically the main
character tier and let's be honest it's
super easy to give a character a sword
and just call them a master swordsman I
mean almost every anime does it because
you don't have to have a complicated
power system or in-depth explanation to
say that someone is a swords master and
I think the perfect example of this is
actually the goblin Slayer from the
anime with the say name because this
author just straight up said Goblin
Slayer is a master of basically every
single weapon in other words yeah not
really convincing me that he is a true
swords master so he does go in this main
character tier however even the main
character swordsman tier is more
impressive than our next tier which is
what I like to call the toothpick tier
and honestly I'm just going to pop it in
Okumura right here because while he does
technically use a sword and we have seen
him use it somewhat in combat the vast
majority of his power actually comes
from his magical blue flames which
leaves his actual sword skills far
behind any of the other characters on
this list and now by this point you
might have realized that this tier list
is not ranked by just how strong a
character is or just their pure sword
skills instead we really have to
consider all of a character's unique
skills and abilities in terms of how it
affects their sword fighting as well
which is why if you're just popping off
magic spells and barely ever use your
sword like Overlord here you're going
straight into that toothpick tier on the
other hand if your magic directly
enhances your sword wielding abilities
like Full Metal Alchemist King Bradley
you then rise up the list and let me
just tell you I've always just loved
Bradley's Powers I mean he can use five
blades and his ultimate eye even lets
him see a little bit into the future as
well as his opponent strength and
weaknesses which is just perfect for the
Superhuman tier also I will just add
here that I'm not exactly sorting each
tier from top to bottom by power in case
you're wondering but even Bradley would
likely get destroyed by UTA oku from JSU
kaisen who is our first character to
land in a special tier outside of the
main five ones we're going to call this
one the swords are my sight hustle tier
which is perfect for characters like UTA
who are yes highly skilled with their
blades but mainly still rely on their
other magical techniques when they're
actually fighting now for this next
ranking though I just have to tell you
about one of these most criminally
underrated and unknown sword fighting
anime which is sword of the stranger and
wow the final battle between nanashi and
LU Lang is just a pure injection of
Samurai Brilliance which lands both of
them in the pure Samurai tier so
seriously go check it out if you haven't
already experienced this true master
class but as much as it pains me to say
it I think both of these characters
would certainly be cut down down by
Nobunaga from Hunter Hunter because
while you could say that Nobunaga sword
techniques aren't any better than
nanashi uang here our favorite Phantom
troop Samurai has the eded benefit of
net enhancement to take their physical
abilities to superhuman levels but now
let's go back right up to the top of
this ranking because it is time to
reveal our second god tier sword fighter
because here we have the captain of the
11th division Kachi from bleach and now
come on how could I not rank him up in
God here he has superhuman strength and
endurance unmatched pure sword skills
and he even restricts his own strength
so that he can enjoy battles for longer
but man when he does unleash his full
potential it is a truly scary side for
all of his opponents and of course as
you can guess this isn't the only
character that we'll see from this
legendary sword fighting anime but do
you think any of the others will
actually make the gods here for one this
next character is so insanely powerful
that he very nearly broke this ranking
because D from Vampire Hunter D is
basically an immortal being who is a
master of literally every weapon that
you could think of and on top of that he
even has reality bending abilities as
well so even though deer uses a sword
and is technically a swordsman I didn't
know where to really put him so I made a
too stupidly powerful tier and just put
him there sorry and actually you could
almost say the same thing for Alibaba
from Magi but his powers are a lot more
reasonable as he's an extremely skilled
swordsman with very quick reflexes and
Hyper awareness of his surroundings but
what truly earns him a spot in the
Superhuman here I think is his fire gin
which allows him to combine his
impressive swordsmanship with scorching
magical Flames but he's still not as
strong as another character from Magi
because simbat has all the same skills
as Alibaba only he has seven element
mental gin instead of just one so bam
let's pop simbba right there enough now
with the magic though let's talk about
one of the most famous Swordsmen in all
of anime and of course I'm talking about
hura Kenshin from the ruoni Kenshin
anime now this man is just the perfect
definition of a pure Samurai he even
fights with the dull edge of his blade
because of his commitment to never kill
again plus he has incredible
determination to protect his friends now
you might be wondering though if we
ranked Kenshin in pure Samurai well what
about his master hio SEO and while
considering Sor Supreme strength and
Mastery of every legendary heaten
mitsurugi technique I don't think anyone
would debate that he far surpasses his
student and ascends straight into the
Superhuman tier this is starting to get
intense and I can uh already feel the
hot flames from the comment section
below but this next ranking might make
even more of you Furious because I'm
ranking sabua from Nar nuto in the
toothpick tier that's right I said it
toothpick for sabua and while he's
undoubtedly many people's favorite
villain from the early parts of Naruto
his actual sword skills just don't
really stack up with the rest of many of
the characters on this list this next
one though might be even more
controversial because it's time to
introduce another one of our special
tiers the to cool for swords tier and
we're kicking this one off with denji
from chainsawman and yeah I know he's
not technically a swordsman but he does
use blades and he is super cool so I
just had to find a special spot for
people like him on this list as well but
right next to dji's tier is the most fun
tier in this ranking with the help my
sword is a life tier and there's no more
perfect character to start of this tier
than yat from honestly one of my
personal favorite anime of all time
Noragami and in case you don't know
yato's blades are literally the living
Souls of that humans that he has bonded
and become friends with so a perfect fit
for this special tier and so what's a
lot more debatable though is asuna's
ranking in this tier list because the
swordswoman from Sword Art Online
conveniently always seems to forget how
to fight when the plot needs her to be a
damsel in distress and so honestly
there's no perfect place for her other
than the main character tier now it's
time for your favorite swords anime's
favorite swordsman gomon from Lupin the
third and this chat from OG anime fights
with his reality bending zanet skin
sword which can cut anything including
buildings helicopters and hilariously
even the fourth wall when he cut the
film sheets off his own anime gomon my
man here breaking barrias everywhere
which is honestly enough I think for him
to just push into the Superhuman tier
but we can't really talk about breaking
barriers without bringing up our next
god tier level character and in a little
bit of a Twist I think this is going to
be a got tier pair because toi fushiguro
and Maki Zayn basically have the same
powers and are both unrivaled when it
comes to sheer physical abilities like
seriously no one touches their pure
strength and durability however their
sword abilities are also truly Next
Level which puts both of them firmly in
the conversation as some of the all-time
strongest characters in all of JSU
kaisen but next I'm going to hit you
with a little bit of a double pure
Samurai Brilliance slash here because
next up we have Jin from Samurai
Champloo who is a brilliant technician
of the purest sords play his moves are
super precise his footwork is Flawless
and he's a model Samurai in every sense
of the word and even though Jinn is
arguably slightly stronger I'm also
going to place mugan right next to his
friend from champ PLO but wow You'll
never meet two Swordsmen so completely
different because mugan has developed
his own sword style based on a
mind-blowing combination of break
dancing and stolen techniques from his
opponents Honestly though I do always
love watching this man fight but from
these incredibly Swordsmen though we now
drop right down into the toothpick here
again with ryuku maty from Killa kill
and as much as I love seeing ryuku
swinging around one half of a giant pair
of scissors to cut down armies of magic
clothes wearing enemies I'd say like 95%
of her power still comes from her own
magic clothes and not from her actual
sword skills themselves but to be fair
at least she's better than Bel kenel
from is it wrong to pick up girls in a
dungeon though because his lack of
confidence and overreliance on Magic
really put him basically at the bottom
of the toothpick tier now this next
ranking is going to hurt some of your
heart even more though because I simply
had to rank Kakashi from Naruto in the
sorts are just my sight hustle tier and
I do know that some of you would love to
see him up in a different tier but
seriously this dude has way too many
Powers if we're being real and we rarely
ever see him fighting with an actual
sword which then as a result it might
make you extra mad then when I next rank
Sasuke all the way up in the superhumans
here because yeah I do get that Sasuke
also has all of these chakra techniques
six path powers susano and the ren again
but the show does put a much greater
emphasis on Sasuke swordsmanship and
even gives him a named blade so yeah
sorry Kakashi fans but Sasuke is without
a doubt the better swordsman at least
and actually joining Sasuke in the
Superhuman tier is a legendary Duo from
Final Fantasy of course I'm talking
about cloud and sephiroth who just both
have these awesome giant blades but hold
on now I I know you're saying Final
Fantasy is a video game but come on I
mean how can I make a sword ranking
video and not include the two of them
plus there is technically a final
fantasy anime so I just don't want to
hear any complaints here which now
brings us to maybe the most famous
swordsman in all of anime the absolute
god tier Black Swordsman himself Kito
from essay oh wait wait hold on that's
that's not right Kito goes uh down here
yes because now it's time for the real
Black Swordsman who is of course guts
from berserk and come on what more do I
really need to say because gut's
unbreakable will leads him to cut down
armies of demons and even fight a
literal God to satisfy his thirst for
vengeance but from a god Slayer this
next swordsman is basically a god
themselves and that's because Reinhardt
from rezero combines his insane natural
sword Talent with his over 100 magical
protections and this makes him so
absurdly powerful that even the author
of the story essentially said that there
is no way to actually kill him which
means I nearly put him in the stupidly
overpowered tier but since he is
seriously talented with his sword I just
couldn't bring my myself to drop him out
of the Gods here however the same can
quite be said for Gilgamesh from fate
though because he is a similar golike
character and he uses so many original
Noble fantasms that he is basically
unbeatable however only one of these
fantasms is actually a sword and that is
of course eia also called the Divergence
sword which is a magical blade capable
of creating World shattering attacks so
yeah he barely counts as a sword user
but I still have to put him in the
stupidly overpowered here which is
actually similar to Yuka from The
greyman Who mostly uses his sword as a
vessel for his many magical attacks he's
not quite as ridiculously strong though
I think so he can go in the uh sight
hustle tier I would say however no one
will argue that gintoki from Gintama
isn't jaw-droppingly powerful because
with his daggering strength and
endurance combined with his straightup
brutal sword skills gintoki is certainly
deserving of the top spot in pure
Samurai for now at least and you might
even argue that gintoki should have been
in super human but one character who
without a doubt does deserve this tier
is theuma from One Piece because in case
you don't know this man is literally a
legend who is even famously known as The
Sword God but still despite that I just
couldn't put him quite into God here
because we just haven't seen him truly
fight in the actual anime so it's really
hard to say and if you think that that
that's insane well then just wait until
you hear that I'm actually also placing
Zoro into the Superhuman category
alongside his distant relative because
yeah I am trying to be fair here no one
piece bias to put Zoro into Gods here
but for now the three Style swordman
just isn't quite strong enough to even
earn the top spot in his own story so I
just can put him into our top 10 in this
ranking though I'm sure he will get
there but even being a hero doesn't save
Kamina from guran Lagan from being
played placed in the main character tier
because yeah while his extra long sword
is kind of cool I've never really been
super impressed with his technique if
I'm being honest and to sink even
further down though next we have vicious
from cowboy bbop who honestly barely
made this ranking in the first place
since he only rarely fights in the story
ever however I do have to give him some
credit for bringing a sword to a show
dominated by guns so Props to him I
can't say the same thing for Inu Yasha
though because even though he possesses
basically the strongest sort in his
entire anime he still mostly fights with
his demon powers claw and raw strength
to win most of his battles nonetheless
shout out to that OG anime though and
actually speaking of the ogs here mji
from blade of the immortal has been
around since the early 90s and man like
he is one of the coolest Swordsmen on
this list he's basically Immortal but
even before he became Immortal he has
won countless death matches as well Plus
he has a breathtaking collection of
beautiful blades which means he simply
must go near the top of the pure Samurai
tier but there's still one character
that will Top even him in this tier
though but for now let's reveal our
sixth god tier sword fighter with Yumi
from Black Clover because without any
doubt he is an incredibly powerful
swordsman but more importantly he's the
perfect example of combining Supreme
swordsman skill with his mind-blowing
magic power to create attacks that can
completely obliterate the environment
and reality itself but if you want a
true samurai Sensei look no further than
haruko from that time I got reincarnated
as a slime because even though this man
was originally an ogre he perfected his
swordplay to a ridiculous degree which
is even more enhanced by his extra
magical senses and right next to him is
the character who said to be on his same
level Hinata sakaguchi and I guess you
wouldn't really know it by looking at
her but she has essentially 2,000 years
worth of battle experience which makes
her inevitably a true swords Master but
I do feel at this point that the
characters in the special tiers are
getting a little bit lonely so let's
jump back into the my sword is a life
tier with big mom from One Piece now
admittedly she mostly really relies on
her raw brutal strength rather than
sword skills but what is very cool here
is that her sword Napoleon has actually
been infused with a piece of her own
soul so that can freely change its size
and even just turn into a hat and
actually sticking around in this same
tier for a second we have the definition
of a living sword with funk fre here now
in case you don't know this sword
literally was infused with a devil fruit
allowing it to transform itself from a
regular blade into a fullon living
elephant yeah I mean uh that that's one
piece for you however now these next two
fighters were almost impossibly hard to
rank and that's because Levi and masika
akran are without a doubt the strongest
non- Tian fighters in all of Attack on
Titan and since they primarily do use
blades and are very similar in abilities
I just had to include them here but
where is the real question I mean
certainly these two have superhuman
abilities and can slice through Titans
with ease but I also think they would
still get wrecked by most of the
Swordsmen in the upper tiers who also
have like magic skills so to be fair
let's just put them in the Superhuman
tier but now we do have one of the
characters with maybe the most unique
weapons which is your from Spy family
and this deadly assessin uses these
lethal stiletto blades to do her bloody
work which makes her perfect for the too
cool for actual swords tier but even
your can't compare to the sheer
Ridiculousness of shii kayui from
katanagatari because hold on just listen
to this shicha learned sord techniques
growing up but instead of using any kind
kind of Blade he uses his bare hands and
feet to slash his opponents like what
and so in other words I guess he's just
absolutely perfect for this specific
category here but now for a character
from am Mana we have Jin Wu from solo
leveling and if you've read the Mana
already then you'll know that Jin Wu is
a master of his dual daggers but his
true power comes from his astonishing
strength magic speed durability and also
healing powers and so I think it's
pretty fair if we just pop him right
into the swords are just my sight hustle
tier which funnily enough is also where
we're going to put the only my hero
Academia character on this list as well
because stain here mostly uses his
blades to cut opponents so that he can
taste their blood and activate his
special Quirk so not quite a traditional
swordsman I would say and while stain
basically idealizes the main character
of my hero akame from akam gak Kil is a
strong swordsman with her famous poison
coated blade wa and while she is
undoubtedly strong I just don't think
that she Stacks up to other characters
on the same tier list so she's going in
the main character tier now this next
one's going to get me into a lot of
trouble though I think because for these
next two characters I'm going to tell
you who they are before we rank them
first we have Ichigo from bleach and
then we have AA from Black Clover one of
them is in G tier and the other is in
superhuman so which is Swit oh man this
is going to piss so many people off but
honestly I just couldn't live with
myself if I hadn't put Ichigo into the
God here because come on he's Ichigo
look at him at the end of the story
which yeah unfortunately means that ASA
is going into superhuman and to be fair
he can summon these anti-magic giant
swords which can cut through any magic
but if he isn't fighting an actual magic
user they're basically just blunt
weapons though he has proven to be
highly effective at using them to defeat
his opponents with his ridiculous power
and speed to show you that I'm not
totally biased towards bleach here
though I'll throw urahara into
superhuman as well even though his
Bankai lets him instantly split anything
in its area of effect so I don't know
maybe that is Gods here but no I think I
think we can leave him right here which
also means that we only have three Gods
here characters left which I really
can't wait to show you but before that
though we have another beloved character
with Torin from Vinland Saga and even
though he isn't a samurai per se he's a
viking I think his sword skills deserve
more than a spot in the main character
tier so we will still put him in the
pure Samurai tier I really can say the
same for sha from shakun Shana though
because even though she is a skilled
swordsman her lack of battle experience
means she often has to rely on her flame
spells so she's just going to go into
the main character tier right next to
Stella Vermillion from chivalry of a
failed Knight because come on even with
her impressive magic Royal Heritage and
years of training she still lost to our
next character in the very first Duel of
the series and of course I'm talking
about iki kurogane and this man
definitely deserves pure Samurai tier
because II taught himself swordsmanship
over the years by watching Masters and
challenging dojos to eventually become
one of the strongest fighters in the
entire world however even iky isn't
quite strong enough for the top of this
legendary tier here though and for me
personally that one belongs to M molal
from the Vagabond manga like seriously
this man is a wild beast of a fighter
with his ridiculous physical strength
guts level unbreakable will and he even
has developed his own two sword style to
maximize offense and defense plus the
art man like wow I I'll never get over
some of the panels in this manga I think
they're just so good but that's still
not enough to beat this next god tier
character though because of course
dracule mihawk from One Piece is
literally known as the strongest
swordsman in the world and with his
world famous blade yuru and his ability
to casually slash through mountains he
certainly deserves his status as a god
tier swordsman but is that enough to
decide the age-old debate about mihawk
versus Shanks I mean in the story we
know that they used to duel and we've
seen just how absolutely soul crushingly
powerful Shanks is as a swordsman but I
still don't know so I'll just leave them
next to each other for right now let me
know what you think in the comments and
if you'd like a whole future video
dedicated to just that topic which just
leaves us with one last GSA character
left but before we get there we have to
talk about gabim Maru from hell's
Paradise who is just a top tier ninja
and honestly he is exceptionally
talented with a sword and kunai but
without a doubt he prefers hand-to hat
combat and using his ridiculous fire
power so sight hustle tier for gabimaru
I think which leaves Motas from the
seven deadly sins as the last sight
Hustler hero because let's be honest of
course he has his sacred treasure sword
lost vein which allows him to clone
himself and Motas is unimaginably strong
but I just think it's a lot less about
his sword skills here and a lot more
about his truly powerful demonic Powers
which does however bring us to melodius
as friend escanor who is too cool for
swords because he uses this giant
onehanded Axe and so while he probably
shouldn't even be on here he's also way
too cool to leave off off this ranking
but how could I of course ever make an
anime tier list without including the
chest anime of it all JoJo which means
that it's time to put paulf into the my
sword is aive tier because his stand
silver Chariot uses a Rapier with
devastating power and skill but don't
think this is just magic though because
paulf has trained with Silva Chariot to
an obser degree to make them both an
incredible sword fighting team and now
somehow I've managed to get away this
long without bringing up one of the most
popular recent sword fighting anime
which is of course Demon Slayer so we
just had to include Tano here and
honestly I considered putting him in the
main character tier but he truly works
super super hard and has come quite a
long way so at this point I do think
that he deserves the pure Samurai tier
yakimaru from Doo isn't quite as lucky
though because even though he's one of
the most interesting characters on this
list just listen to this since his body
parts were all stolen by demons his
current body is mostly made up of
artificial parts that can shoot out
chemicals poisons and explosives however
just considering his sword skills
nothing he did really impressed me
enough to move him out of the main
character tier but even yakimaru gets
more credit than Aki from chainsaw man
who initially used a sword but then
mostly relies on his devil contracts
which in the end lands him in the
toothpick tier which is the same fate as
for Arthur Bole from fire force and
honestly Arthur was one of the hardest
characters to judge because he does
fight with a sword made of flames but he
does suffer from very low confidence for
the most part of the story plus there
are almost no other sword users in the
story so because of all of that it will
be the toothpick tier for Archer as well
now one man who has no lack of
confidence though is Shion from hell's
Paradise because even though he is
literally blinded he has deadly fast
sword skills that can cut down even the
strongest enemies with East and even
though he eventually gets physical Boost
from wuta Shion is still the definition
of a pure Samurai for me which now
actually brings us to some of maybe the
most fun characters to rank here
starting with demon I and while this man
has insane demonic and spiritual Powers
which give him tremendous healing boosts
and physical strength Elemental attacks
based on the Chinese xijin and even an
intimidating Aura to destroy an
opponent's will to fight oh yeah and
he's also of course a ridiculously
skilled swordsman seriously what an
insane character who fully deserves the
Superhuman here but it's debatable
though if he's stronger than Atomic
samurai from one punch man who can slash
100 times in a single second which I
mean if that's not superhuman then I
don't know what is really close to the
god tier actually and this next one is
going to make some people really Furious
though I think because now we have
guts's main rival Griffith from berserk
and even though they were technically
basically even in the Golden Age Arc I
just can't put them on the same level so
Griffith goes to superhuman tier as well
which is the exact same tier as for Erza
from fairy tale and while she's
definitely not the strongest character
in this tier she has some of the highest
versatility in the entire ranking that's
because her expertise with her requip
magic allows her to swap between over
200 100 different blades which is
certainly impressive and maybe the
highest in this entire ranking which now
brings us to Yori Ichi from Demon Slayer
who was so powerful that he could even
terrify a literal Godlike demon like
seriously he's basically the Godfather
of demon Slayers and even without any
crazy magic abilities in my opinion he
is the greatest pure swordsman in this
entire ranking which does in the end
earn him a spot in the god tier and I'll
be completely honest though there was
actually one more character who was so
close to making the gods here and that
is he from yuu Haku show who is
undoubtedly a godtier fighter but since
he uses so many Magic based attacks
alongside his swordsmanship I just
couldn't quite put him in the god tier
of this ranking in fact one of these
magic abilities is a fiery blast so
powerful it can literally turn people
into dust and even though he didn't make
the gati here if you want to see how
high these fire powers pushed here on
ranking of every fire user in anime you
can check out that video right here
thanks for watching all the way here and
I will see you in the next one